hello and welcome to see are playing
bones again I just had him earlier today
and probably the video was out yesterday
so it's always a slow time time
situations then I'm up so now it was FYE
place all the all the main moves I can
surpass I really hate this by now that
you get this this is opening all all the
time ok I probably have to react to it
somehow hmm really if I go g5 and then
tikki for is that it's it's very cheeky
I have to say it's very cheeky
but is it bad that's the thing come on
show me if it's bad it's bad i cannot do
much about it so take first ask
questions later so just this move okay
um so here at least and i should be able
to take this and now what about g4g for
and then 9085 is that is that possible
if i just take with the night you can
take take da a take up seven this isn't
bad actually this is actually quite good
for like but g4 looks more interesting
and then taking on e5 with the night it
should be quite quite an exciting
position actually maybe you can do
something something crazy like really
crazy is the wrong word like check on
this six okay it didn't go for that
okay here i have a super cool plan and
i'm going to do it i'm just too tempted
by stuff like that age 5 h for checkmate
on the H file and this Bishop on a seven
this is what below God coined the black
shark it's a fairly dangerous piece so
what's the deal here okay I can take and
I probably should take I can also take C
fault this is very slow development
why's it still may be pretty good
actually you can take them King kills to
f8 and I go H voice is a very dangerous
attack let's do it and the key one of
eight is fairly safe its really fairly
safe and have a porn up so I think this
looks pretty nice it looks pretty nice
okay if eight is a very you looks like a
decent square for the king the only
thing that I can think of okay I can
also go age three here
um okay simplest of course is to just
take it and then go from there I Queen
have six or something maybe queen is
Queen f6 just like that it also could I
age six and the possibility f5 night is
six looks like an idea but this is
pinned I mean that's not happening I
have to if I'm precisely i'm going to
win this game but i have to be precise
mmm and that makes an awful lot of sense
with Nala moose is going to just be
killed so is he threatening anything
first of all I don't see it something
taking here first and if I take a five
now FTX queen age four yes I'm is six at
the end yes e six
take Stig screen age 4 i'm not sure that
this is so easily winning takes take 36
i take too much time I mean something
like that this is a technical in but
maybe I could have just taken it now
I've got one minute to spend too much
time down should it just be me she's
just be more pragmatic I'm a pawn up the
whole time and I've got two bishops
against two night so maybe em it was a
it will see I should have just played
this after some seconds and not just try
to try to justify taking it which of
course I mean probably was possible but
far more difficult to to play and
evaluate I can't so he's running into a
pin here I Kingi three actually I can I
came care that's
every time learning but it's time spend
so I'm going for an ending which is
easier to play I think with the time
it's somewhat better for black bit of
course not as good as it should have
been considering how the position walls
hmm maybe I'm completely miss playing
this stuff very much possible yeah I'm
gonna pull down or something jack is
pretty crazy no I'm not a paw down check
be five looks wrong actually check
autumn is countdown I'm quicker isg porn
is also quite fast but no my pawns
should promote on their own put a type
of game check it's actually lucky that
I'm in that pin here check flight
forfeits on time okay so yeah I probably
could have could have just ended this
much quicker here with with taking the
night I just I just I just couldn't I
just couldn't bring myself doing it okay
the engine just does that and over c4
huh it's of course very strong argument
and hit that if quite a number of nights
attacked but could I could have taken it
i mean probably I mean very likely I
could have taken it but i was thinking
here and then some e 6 I mean yeah
should be 60 rupees i can take with the
Queen ah of course so this doesn't
really do all that much now ok then then
i can just take i had some i was
thinking also I made a mistake actually
I was thinking I would take always first
and then capture somehow and here i mean
i felt like it six is kind of tricky but
it's not i can just take it yeah so that
was just completely off a way of
thinking
I mean here it's it's a great ending but
it's not what I could have had and here
we look King g3 yeah going into the
route bending and was just a pragmatic
decision because I was down on time and
I felt I can I can just play quicker
moves but if that was a good position
i'm pretty much doubt the engine likes
white after work she forms or king at
five and here it says equal check and
after that i can start to play for wind
up you want a stronger that's very
difficult to play with the Chinese time
restraints yeah this this is prolly
check probably shouldn't win yeah this
losers he has to take I promote first
but this is the draw and after that I'm
winning well now until the endless was
not all that difficult while a tough
tough fighting game okay well thanks for
watching